We're so excited about our second annual Cicada Day because it brings together so many different groups.
Thank you all very much for coming and also for those of you who have worked so hard, and the teachers particularly, we owe a lot to you.
My name is Kay Clemente. I'm from Mypaw High School.
Okay, so my project is this one. It's about my classmate's great-great-grandfather who was a former Cicada worker.
He came here in 1946 after World War II, and their sacrifices helped to build a community and understanding of hard work.
My name is Elaine Beltran. I'm from Mypaw High School. I'm a senior.
It's important to honor our Cicada legacy because without them, we wouldn't have better opportunities here, like better immigrant rights.
As someone as an immigrant too, I'm very thankful that they fight for our rights for today, and yeah.
My name is Maydel Antonio. My husband Jamel.
And I am Marcus Mizraq Antonio.
Antonio, and he goes to Dream House, Ebba Beach.
Hello.
He's one of the senior, and actually, we're very excited to support him here in this event.
So, it's very good to go back to your roots and learn about it.
To see all of you here today, it's really a great feeling.
And the Filipino history and culture is huge here in Hawaii.
So, I just want to thank you all very much for all the work that you do, for the event coordinators,
for helping to celebrate a wonderful Filipino culture and history at Sakada Day,
and honoring the initial immigrants that came here to Hawaii.
Our game is inspired by reality, like hope, Sakadas, like who, like Philippines.
As we reflect to the Sakadas legacy, let us remember the words of Dr. Osirisal,
that you are the hope of the fatherland.
That hope shines brightly in the faces of the young people with us today.
We embody the living legacy of the Sakadas,
breaching the struggles of the past with the promise of tomorrow.
We know that education is so, so empowering and important for students.
As Filipinos, we are so, so strong together.
And it's important to look at history to understand that we have always been a people who are resilient.
My grandfather and the Sakadas, they left the Philippines with so much hope,
with a sense of adventure event, to come here.
And what did they do? What did they achieve?
They achieved, they established us.
They established a generation of Filipino Americans.
One in every four persons here in Hawaii is of Filipino American descent.
So that you get the Omelan.
Young people, friends, kukabayan, the hope of our country, break the end.
Through the page. Write your story. What is it, Kanadi?
The event overall, this is the first time I'm attending it.
And I think it's really awesome that the student groups,
and I'm interested and curious about that stuff.
So it was cool to learn from the students.
It wasn't me teaching them, it was the students teaching us.
I wanted to incorporate the hardships and strength, determination that the Sakadas face.
There was a lot of cool things.
One of the coolest things I saw was a comic book, which was created with AI,
but it told the story so perfectly.
And just learning about the legacy of where Sakada came from and where your ancestry came from.
It's very important to lead on into the future and to tell your grandkids and,
you know, just the foundation of where you came from.
And the leader.
Okay, the name is Tiang, Ray, and Daya.
Ray and Daya.
When do you go to the Philippines?
Oh, visit my family there. I've never been there to walk in.
Oh!